hi this is preshtalwaker in this video
we'll discuss the length of a helix or a
spiral
consider a cylinder where we have a
spiral that's drawn from the bottom of
one end to the top of the other that
loops around one time the puzzle is what
is the length of this spiral
we're going to say the cylinder has a
height of 3
and the circumference of the base will
be equal to 4.
can you figure out what the length of
the spiral is
go ahead and give it a try
when you have a solution or you're ready
you can keep watching to see
the solution that we present
all right you could solve this
by parameterizing the spiral
and using the equation for arc length
but being a puzzle there's a trick
we unwrap the cylinder to form a
rectangle
and now the spiral is the diagonal of
this rectangle
this rectangle has a height of three
and the length of the rectangle will be
the circumference of the circle which is
equal to four
so we can solve for the length of the
spiral
as the length of the hypotenuse of the
right triangle with legs 3 and 4 and
this will be equal to 5.
did you solve it
i hope you liked this video please
subscribe to my channel you can support
me on patreon
catch me on my blog mindyourdecisions
on twitter at preshtalwalker
and you can get my books listed on my
website